Immanuel Kant is a philosopher who tried
to work out how human beings could be
good and kind outside of the
exhortations and blandishments of
traditional religions he was born in
1724 in the baltic city of königsberg
which at that time was part of prussia
and now belongs to russia renamed
Kaliningrad kans parents were very
modest his father was a saddle maker
Kant never had much money a fact he
dealt with cheerfully by living very
modestly it wasn't until he was in his
50s that he became a fully salaried
professor and attained a moderate degree
of prosperity his family were deeply
religious and very strict later in life
Kant did not have any conventional
religious beliefs but he was acutely
aware of just how much religion had
contributed to his parents ability to
cope with all the hardships of their
existence and how useful religion could
be in fostering social cohesion and
community Kant was physically very
slight frail and anything but
good-looking yet he was very sociable
and some of his colleagues used to
criticize him for going to too many
parties when eventually he was able to
entertain he had rules of that
conversation at his table at the start
of a dinner party he decreed that people
should swap stories about what had been
happening recently then there should be
a major phase of reflective discourse in
which those present attempted to clarify
an important topic and finally there
should be a closing period of hilarity
so that everyone left in a good mood he
died in 1804 in his 80th year in
königsberg having rarely felt the need
to spend any time outside the city in
which he was born
Kant was writing at a highly interesting
period in history we now know as the
Enlightenment in an essay called what is
enlightenment published in 1784 can't
propose that the identifying feature of
his age was it's growing secularism
intellectually Kant welcomed the
declining belief in Christianity but in
a practical sense he was also alarmed by
it he was a pessimist about human
character and believed that we are by
nature intensely prone to corruption it
was this awareness that led him to
formulate what would be his life's
project the desire to replace religious
authority
with the authority of reason that is
human intelligence when it came to
religion can summed up his views in a
book entitled religion within the bounds
of reason alone here he argued that
although historical religions had all
been wrong in the content of what they'd
believed they had latched on to a great
need to promote ethical behavior a need
which still remained it was in this
context that kant came up with the idea
for which he is perhaps still most
famous what he called the categorical
imperative this strange sounding term
first appeared in a horrendously named
work groundwork of the metaphysics of
morals the categorical imperative states
act only according to that maxim by
which you can at the same time will that
it should become a universal law what it
can mean by this this was only a very
formal restatement of an idea that's
been around for a long time something we
meet with in all the main religions do
unto others as you would have them do
unto you
Kant was offering a handy way of testing
the morality of an action by imagining
how it would be if it would generally
practiced and you with a victim of it it
might be tempting to Filch a few pads of
paper from the station recovered at work
it seems like a small thing but if
everyone did this the cupboard and
society at large would need a lot of
guards similarly if you have an affair
and keep it quiet from your partner you
might feel that's okay but the
categorical imperative comes down
against this because you would then have
to embrace the idea that it would be
equally okay for your partner to have
affairs and not tell you the categorical
imperative is designed to shift our
perspective to get us to see our own
behavior in less immediately personal
terms and thereby recognize some of its
limitations Kant went on to argue that
the core idea of the categorical
imperative
could be stated in another way act so as
to treat people always as ends in
themselves never as mere means this was
intended as a replacement for the
Christian injunction for universal love
the command to love one's neighbor to
treat a person as an N
for Kant meant keeping in view that they
had a life of their own in which they
were seeking happiness and fulfillment
and deserved justice and fair treatment
the categorical imperative Kant argued
is the voice of our own rational selves
it's what we all truly believe when
we're thinking sensibly it's the rule
our own intelligence gives us Kant
extended is thinking about the
categorical imperative into the
political sphere he believed that the
central duty of government is to ensure
liberty but he sense that there was
something terribly wrong with the
ordinary definition of freedom or
Liberty it should not be thought of in
libertarian terms as the ability to do
just whatever we want we are free only
when we act in accordance with our own
best natures and we are slaves whenever
we are under the rule of our own
passions or those of others as can put
it a free will and a will under moral
laws are one and the same so freedom
isn't an absence of government a free
society isn't one that allows people
more and more opportunity to do whatever
they happen to fancy it's one that helps
everyone become more reasonable the good
state represents the rational element in
us all it rules according to a
universally valid will under which
everyone can be free
so government ideally is the
externalized institutionalized version
of the best parts of ourselves it might
be a bit surprising at first to discover
that in 1793 Kant published a major work
on beauty and art the critique of
judgment it might seem like a bit of a
sideline for a thinker otherwise
concerned with politics and ethics but
Kant held that his ideas about art and
beauty with the cornerstones of his
entire philosophy as we've been seeing
can thought that life involved a
constant struggle between our better
selves and our passions between duty and
pleasure Beauty can't especially liked
roses vines apple trees and birds
delights us in a very special and
important way it's a reminder of and
good to our better selves unlike so much
else in our lives our love of beauty is
in Cannes word disinterested it takes us
out of our narrow selfish concerns but
charming delightful way without being
Stern or demanding the beauty of nature
is a continual quiet and insistent
reminder of our common Universal being a
pretty flower is just as attractive to
the tired farm worker as to the prince
the graceful flight of a swallow is as
lovely to a child as to the most learned
professor for Kant the role of art is to
embody the most important ethical ideas
it's a natural extension of philosophy
Kant held that we needed to have art
continually before us so as to benefit
from vivid illustrations and memorable
symbols of good behavior and thereby
keep the wayward parts of ourselves in
check counts books were dense abstract
and highly intellectual but in them he
sketched a very important project that
remains crucial to this day he wanted to
understand how the better more
reasonable parts of our nature's could
be strengthened so as to reliably win
out over all inbuilt weaknesses and
selfishness as Kant saw it he was
engaged in the task of developing a
secular rational version of what
religions had very imperfectly always
attempted to do help us to be good
you